[Music]
this episode is sponsored by fabulous an
app that helps you form healthy habits
that stick
click the link in the description to get
a free week trial and 25
off a fabulous subscription
this is not an organism at least it's
not
yet anyway what we are looking at are a
lot of
zoospores packed together getting ready
to be released
so that they can find the right place to
grow into themselves
and this well this is a male tardigrade
filled from head to many toes
with sperm just chock full of it
[Music]
we did not start this channel with the
intent of becoming
so familiar with tardigrade mating
habits but tardigrades are easy to find
and their mating habits are
straightforward enough to track
so we keep getting drawn back into the
details and the drama
of tardigrade reproduction in the past
we've talked about the particulars of
their mating habits and
today we're going to use this tardigrade
as a convenient starting point to talk
about
the history of our understanding of
sperm because as absurd as it might seem
to be looking at tardigrade sperm the
theories
people have had about sperm are
much weirder humans
have been theorizing about the contents
of seminal fluid
long before the invention of the
microscope
we did not as a species need to work out
all of the scientific mechanisms
underlying sexual reproduction
to make babies but the observation of
children who carried traits from their
parents naturally raised questions
about how those traits were passed on
and those questions inevitably led
to some hypotheses and look not all
hypotheses
need to be good in fact many of them are
terrible
it's just that when you're trying to
understand the world you need to start
somewhere
and as long as you're willing to work
with your ideas and challenge them
then hopefully someday you go from
somewhere
to somewhere better
some of these early ideas about sperm
weren't just
bad though they were maybe as we should
expect a little self-serving to the male
ego masturbatory even you could say
like the theory now known as spermism
advocated for by one pythagoras yes
that pythagoras according to spermism
the information driving heredity came
entirely through the semen
whether that was the color of someone's
hair or their height or
whatever other trait all of that came
through the father
and the father's father and so on the
mother's role was just to provide
nourishment to the sperm as it developed
and manifested those traits
it's easy enough to find flaws with this
idea after all our observed reality
which pythagoras just chose to ignore
shows us that traits pass
from mother and father alike but this
would not be the last theory
to overestimate the sperm even with the
advance of scientific tools over the
ages there was plenty to get
wrong one of those key scientific tools
was of course
the microscope which allowed scientists
to observe the cells
within semen for the first time
but just because microscopists could see
sperm now
that did not mean that they could make
out the details
and this invited speculation including
the idea
that we are essentially developed from a
much
smaller version of ourselves this theory
was called pre-formationism
at the end of the 17th century the dutch
scientist nicolas hartselker
sketched out his spermist vision of
pre-formationism
inside the head of the sperm cell he
speculated was a very
very very small human later called a
homunculus
just waiting for a womb to grow in
and look we have the advantage of
centuries of advancements
to know that the homunculus was wrong
but maybe take a moment to just think
about
how weird that would be if it were right
look at this tardigrade full of sperm
and then just imagine
if we zoomed in further on those sperm
cells and we could see
little tiny tardigrades inside of them
and then
if we could zoom in even more on those
tinier tardigrades we'd see
even more tinier tardigrades inside of
them
and so on and so on now to be clear
that is not what tardigrade sperm looks
like their sperm is made up of
a slightly globular head connected to a
flagellum
but as wrong as both spermism and tiny
people
inside of sperm turned out to be they're
not that
far off the mark if you think about the
zoospores
we showed at the beginning of the
episode they are a tool
of asexual reproduction and a lot of
different organisms including
algae fungi and bacteria they all use
zoospores in different ways
and because we don't know exactly what
organism these zoospores come from there
are specific details of their lives we
just don't know
but take for example the phytophthora a
group of oomy seeds
most notorious for their role in the
19th century potato blight
that led to the great famine in ireland
phytophthora can reproduce sexually but
they mostly rely on making
asexual zoospores which pack together
in a biological enclosure called the
sporangia
until the conditions are right for their
release and when they emerge
from the sporangia the zoospores
start swimming using their flagella and
chemical sensors
to find the ideal place to settle and
germinate
all of the hereditary information in
those zoospores came from one parent
fashioning an organism that resembles
the infant form of that parent
and that seeks only nourishment from its
new host
the outlines of that process sound
pretty similar to how early philosophers
and scientists
envisioned their sperm-centric ideas of
sexual reproduction
but what those scientists missed what
separates the sperm
from the zoospore is the nature of
sexual reproduction
itself of the genetic variation
it drives by combining and recombining
traits from different parents sperm
cannot accomplish that on their own
sperm need
an ovum to fertilize which scientists
would eventually uncover
in the 19th century with experiments on
rabbits
sea urchins and starfish eggs that
helped
to further our understanding of the
molecular and
cellular collaboration that set the
stage
for inheritance yes my friends as
napoleon
drove to conquer europe we had no idea
that sperm and eggs came together to
make the next generation
there are a lot of different types of
spores out there used both for sexual
and asexual reproduction and in contrast
sperm might seem more narrow and focused
both in diversity
and in purpose but the function of sperm
is so specialized that it requires its
own diversity
even among tardigrades there are
different morphologies
to the head and middle structures of the
sperm small differences that distinguish
between species
and that's because however weird our
theories about sperm have been
the reality is also very strange
of all the cells in the body sperm cells
are maybe the only ones that are
expected to navigate and survive
in two different beings the homunculus
was wrong but the idea of there being an
image of our life passed on within
sperm and in spores it isn't absurd at
all
it's just too literal instead that image
is
abstracted and tucked away into genetic
information
and zoospores and sperm alike are just
packets
of that information swimming off to new
and different futures
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and thank you to
fabulous
for sponsoring this episode fabulous is
an app that was born at duke university
and uses behavioral science research to
gently support your personal goals
habit changing and habit building is
hard
so if you're looking for ways to add a
new thing to your routine
fabulous is the way to go it's the
number one self-care and habit-forming
app in the app store
with over 20 million users and it can
help you whether you're looking for ways
to stay focused at work
or you just need a reminder to take a
break once in a while to stretch
and drink some water the app is 100
personalized to your goals
and you can start building your ideal
daily routine today
the first 100 people who click on the
link in the description will get a free
week
trial and 25 off a fabulous subscription
thank you to all the people on the
screen right now our patreon patrons are
amazing and they're the reason that we
can make this show if you would like to
join them
and be a part of that and also get some
access to some special
stuff that is only available to patrons
you can go to patreon.com
journey to micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes james
weiss you can check out
jam and germs on instagram and if you
want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
you